ce stationner gratuitement à Montréal
sera-t-il bientôt chose du passé le
conseil régional de l'environnement
dépose un livre blanc sur le sujet et
son constat est clair une place de
stationnement sur rue coûte trop cher à
la société et pas assez aux
automobilistes la valeur à l'échelle de
la municipalité c'est 1275 dollars sur
l'île de Montréal pour une case de
stationnement sur rue donc on voudrait
graduellement se rendre à ce montant là
qui soit assumé par les automobilistes
plutôt par l'ensemble de la population
l'organisme a fait le calcul des
subventions actuelles en fonction du
mode de transport il en vient à la
conclusion que lorsqu'un automobiliste
investit un dollar pour utiliser son
véhicule la société en paye presque 10
fois plus dans une ville comme Montréal
ou 30% des ménages ont pas de voiture
c'est une question de justice parce que
présentement lorsque les gens vont faire
leurs emplettes à pied ils paient dans
le prix de leurs aliments le
stationnement des usagers qui viennent
en voiture équitation gratuitement mais
de là à faire payer près de 1300 dollars
par an je peux tellement d’accord parce
que déjà ça coûte déjà assez cher d'être
à Montréal puis je veux dire les taxes
sont déjà assez élevées c'est
probablement les limites qui fait qu'on
un jour on va déménager ça va
probablement dissuader certaines
personnes de souliers en auto de gader
au loto de d'acheter une auto la Ville
de Montréal qui veut revoir
l'utilisation de ces bordures de rue et
faire plus de place aux mobilité douce
accueille favorablement ce livre blanc
mais tempère un peu on en est pas là oui
à terme il va avoir des modifications au
niveau de la tarification du
stationnement dans certains secteurs ce
sera pas fait de manière unilatérale les
vignettes sont gratuites ou inexistantes
dans 5 arrondissements sur 19
aujourd'hui ailleurs elle coûte entre 11
et 270 dollars par an le livre blanc
renferme une vingtaine d'autres
propositions comme faire une plus grande
place à l'autopartage et utiliser
jusqu'à un tiers de l'espace des
stationnements en dehors des rues pour y
construire des logements ici Mathieu
Prost Radio-Canada Montréal